افاد مراسل الجزيره من جنوب قطاع غزه بان
قوات الاحتلال تقصف بشكل متقطع مناطق عده
في مدينه خان يونس حيث استخدمت سلاح
المدفعيه والطائرات المسيره وكان مراسلنا
قد افاد في الساعات الماضيه عن اصابه
اثنين من النازحين نتيجه قصف اسرائيلي
لمنزل في محيط المستشفى الاوروبي بخان
يونس كما سجل وقوع غاره جويه بالتزامن مع
قصف مدفعي استهدف وسط وغرب مدينه خان يونس
جنوب القطاع واشار مراسلنا الى استمرار
قوات الاحتلال في محاصره المستشفيات لاسما
مستشفى الامل ومستشفى ناصر و تعمد طائرات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المسيره الى استهداف
اي جسم يتحرك في هذه المناطق وفي غزه ايضا
افاد مراسلنا بوقوع اشتباكات بين المقاومه
وقوات الاحتلال تسمع اصواتها في المناطق
الغربيه لمدينه غزه
ونذهب الان الى مراسلنا من رفح هشام زقوط
هشام اخر التطورات
لديك اخر التطورات هي مزيد من القصف
الاسرائيلي خاصه في خانيونس الجيش
الاسرائيلي يركز عمليته العسكريه في
خانيونس ومنذ بداها قبل اكثر من اسبوع وهو
يركز على المناطق الغربيه لخان يونس اعاد
التموضع والتمركز بالامس في مناطق مختلفه
لكن الجيش اسرائيلي ما زال يتواجد يحاصر
المدينه ويمنع الدخول اليها وخاصه دخول
المساعدات الطبيه والمساعدات الغذائيه الى
السكان المتواجدين في مدينه خان يونس
وايضا النازحين الذين لجوا الى المستشفيات
سواء كان مستشفى ناصر في مدينه خان يونس
او حتى مستشفى الامل التابع للهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني ما زال يتواجد هناك المئات من
الفلسطينيين
ونازحون جلهم من النازحين الذين اتوا الى
ولجوا الى هذه المراكز على على اساس انها
امنه الان هم محاصرون من قبل الدبابات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه اطلاق القذائف مستمر
على محيط مستشفى ناصر وهذا المستشفى ربما
هو المستشفى الاكبر الان في قطاع غزه بسبب
خروج مستشفى الشفاء عن الخدمه والان كل
مستشفيات القطاع تعاني من جراء محاصره هذا
المستشفى نحن نتحدث عن المستشفى الذي
يحتوي على العدد الاكبر من غرف العمليات
العدد الاكبر من غرف العنايه المكثفه وفي
رفح وفي وسط القطاع المست المستشفيات
المتواجده هي مستشفيات صغيره وكانت تلجا
الى مستشفى ناصر من خلال تحويل الاصابات
الخطيره الى هذا المستشفى من اجل اجراء
العمليات هناك الان حتى هذه المستشفيات
محرومه من تحويل الجرحى وهذا بكل تاكيد
يهدد حياه المرضى ويهدد حياه الجرحى
بالاضافه الى ان مدينه رفح يتكدس فيها
السكان نحو مليون و300 ال نسمه وهناك
العشرات من المرضى خاصه مرضى الفشل القلوي
الذين يحتاجون الى اجهزه لغ سيل الكلى لكن
هذه الاجهزه غير متوفره لهذا العدد الكبير
وبالتالي كان كانوا يلجؤون الى مستشفى
ناصر من خلال تحويل بعض المرضى الى هناك
الان هذا عمليه التحويل متوقفه عمليه
الامداد للغذاء ولدوا ايضا متوقفه وهناك
بحسب وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه الطواقم
تعاني من الجوع تعاني من نقص حاد في
الادويه تعاني من نقص حاد في المياه
الخاصه والصالحه للشرب خاصه بعد ان قام
الجيش الاسرائيلي وت تيرت الشظايا بعمليات
القصف من خلال قام الجيش الاسرائيلي بقصف
المنازل المحيطه لمستشفى ناصر وبالتالي
تطايرت الشرايا الى المستشفى
ودمرت خزانات المياه الخاصه بالمستشفى
وبالتالي الجيش الاسرائيلي مازال يركز
عمليته على خانيونس يحاصر المنطقه
والشوارع الرئيسيه والمفترق الاساسيه
المؤديه من مدينه خانيونس الى مدينه رفح
يسيطر عليها الجيش الاسرائيلي ونصب حاجزا
هناك وما زال يعتقل الرجال ويترك النساء
للذهاب الى مدينه رفح بلا ماوى يجرده من
كافه اغراضهم من امتعتهم ومن اي شيء
يحملونه ويجبرهم على النزوح الى مدينه رفح
واذا اتوا الى رفح فهم ياتوا الى المدينه
المكتظه التي لا يوجد فيها متسع لا خيام
لا ماوى لا غذاء لا دواء لا مياه ايضا في
ظل هذه الاعداد الكبيره التي لا تستطيع اي
سلطه او اي جهه توفير الخدمات لكل هؤلاء
النازحين الذين اتوا ونصبوا خياما في كافه
المناطق هشام زقوت مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا
من رفح اشكرك